this case involved data on fourth and
fifth graders using a fractions tutor we
used causal discovery algorithms that
suggested that teaching students to
understand the subject deeply before
they become fluent in it would help them
learn a future experiment confirm that
the fraction suitor is an intelligent
tutoring system that uses a cognitive
model of students knowledge over 3,000
students have participated in classroom
experiments with the tutor these
experiments showed that students who use
the tutor four-week improved their test
scores by between 32 and 48 percent in
particular students who were taught to
use multiple graphical representations
make pie charts rectangles and number
lines learned more than students who
used only a single representation but we
didn't know by which mechanisms learning
was occurring to get insight we decided
to tap into the data we had collected to
build and test causal models of students
learning graphical causal models have
been used extensively in the last few
decades they've been used for fMRI
research genetics and more recently
educational research the problem is
there's trillions of possible models
that can explain the patterns you see in
the data luckily we've seen some
algorithms developed lately that will
actually search this space and come up
with a small set of models that are
plausible go here with your background
knowledge and explain what you see in
the data we first used causal models on
the variables typically used to
represent mechanisms of learning number
of errors number of hint requests the
time spent total it turned out that none
of these variables revealed mechanisms
that were going on in this case to
identify better variables we turn to
theories about learning which led us to
consider a sense making influency for
fractions sense making means to
understand how different representations
to pick the same information fluency
means to quickly and effortlessly use
these representations when we applied
causal discovery to our data we found
evidence that
it's making enhances fluency but not
vice versa button it to the new
prediction that we should support
sense-making before fluency when we
teach fractions we tested this and a new
experiment that compared students who
worked on sense-making before fluency or
on fluency before since making the
results confirmed our hypothesis since
making before fluency led to the best
learning gains
so to summarize in this case we had rich
data collected on hundreds of students
state-of-the-art data analytic methods
and learning science which yielded a
prediction and an insight which was
later confirmed in an experiment